pmj I have another name for you Craven
he's here on some kind of hunt
no if you need me I'm just a call away
what the hell's going on with Keith he's
not himself
this was our dream
we've got a lot to talk about so first
Brian my first question for you is where
do we find Peter MJ Harry and miles at
the beginning of Marvel Spider-Man 2 now
that we're in the the third installment
of the franchise well you could find us
all in the back being late to the panel
because we're watching the story trailer
as you guys were all watching it
backstage first off so
um yeah I think it is what's really
great about this game is that we're
gonna pick up roughly nine to ten months
after um the events of Miles Morales
which even played it it's an amazing
video game by The Talented team and
what's really great is we kind of have
Pete miles they're a well-oiled machine
they're a great team they lean on each
other they really support each other and
they're really protecting the city but
same time there's a lot of things going
on in their life outside the mask uh
miles is applying to college and trying
to figure out how to write his college
essay and you know Pete starting his uh
teaching career and then you have MJ who
is still at the bugle but um under a new
leadership with the return of J Jonah
Jameson at The Daily News
[Applause]
and then bill so my next question is for
you so what can you talk about the
dynamic of these characters and how
working with Insomniac they're keeping
the authentic authenticity of the DNA of
these the core of these characters while
still making it their own together
working all together we're all one team
uh we all love the characters we're all
our goal is to make something that you
love that when you play you say this was
made by fans for fans oh yeah
and John my next question is for you
with the the new villains that we've
seen in this this game confirmed
villains with Craven Venom and lizard he
talked narratively why you felt those
choices for those villains were
important for us it really started with
Craven uh he's our Catalyst for for the
story right like he you know before the
game starts he's Halfway Around the
World being Craven uh hunting uh trying
to find the ultimate prey and he watched
from afar as the events of the first two
games occurred
um and he decided you know what there's
a lot of stuff going on in New York City
that that might be my new hunting ground
so
um like I said Craven's a catalyst for
for everything happening when he comes
to to New York City
you know a lot of things start start
going wrong uh you know uh we we have
lizard
um coming coming out we have uh the
Symbiote uh coming out
um and and as you saw briefly in in that
trailer
um miles is forced to to come face to
face with the Mr negative the the guy
who killed his dad so there's a lot of
drama uh that that's happening
um in this game absolutely and just into
my next question for you so I think one
of the things fans really appreciate
about both of the games is just the
environment just the lived in cities
that it feels it feels like a character
in its own so can you talk about how you
elevated that with this new game
especially with the PS5 technology and
the new locations that we'll see like
with Coney Island and queens and stuff
like that
Queens to our fans
miles is from Brooklyn
um
not only does it increase the gameplay
space so there's a lot more uh places
for you to swing to but it also has some
really cool obviously Marvel landmarks
as well as New York landmarks for
example I know in Queens everybody has
wanted to visit Aunt May's house and
perhaps we'll see where Peter lives I
know a lot of fans had wanted to
interact with that space so just be able
to like walk in and see where he lives
is incredible oh and there's a picture
of Aunt May's house
um the other thing that's really cool is
it's introducing a lot of cool landmarks
like the East River so as you can see in
our gameplay uh trailer that we produced
a while back you can now chase the
lizards on the East River which is
awesome and personally for me I just
love seeing the Brooklyn Bridge the
Williamsburg Bridge and being able to
just swing across the water it's an
incredible experience and Ryan my next
question for you just following up with
the new locations can you talk about how
the the new traversal techniques that
we're implementing in this game affected
what you approach your approach to this
and how you elevated it sure I mean one
of the interesting things with Brooklyn
and Queens is you're not always
surrounded by skyscrapers anymore and so
we thought what's a really great
opportunity something we've seen on
comic book covers we've seen it in the
movies we can add the web wings and that
that was really changed how we look at
traversal swinging is always our
Spider-Man Core that's where we come
from but what we did is design the web
Wing so that we could integrate them and
weave them in with swinging you gain
height and you build speed between
swinging and the web wings and you go
back and forth and really really kind of
weave your way through the city it's
really fun in Brooklyn and Queens there
are some lower spaces there are some new
spaces but you have you have to get
between Manhattan and the other boroughs
by crossing the river so that's another
opportunity where we could really uh
well we added these things called jet
streams or wind tunnels you really build
speed there and they just shoot you
right along when you're on the web Wings
it's really fun and you know it's one of
the chances for us to really push the
power of the PS5 there and like hit a
level of speed that we hadn't had in the
previous game it's really added a new
dimension to what we can do with
traversal we do see we do we see Mr
negative in this trailer so can you just
briefly talk a little bit about how he's
still coping with the effects of his
game and dealing with the loss of his
father man well y'all seen Mao's
trajectory you know and just with
everything that he's been through with
his family and his friends and just
getting into this new world that he's
you know being introduced to but he's
now owning this this power but you know
um coming back to Martin Lee man that
was something big I didn't think that we
would uh revisit that because we had a
lot of emotions on set and my last
question because we touched on it as
well but his powers and his abilities
how is he really we see them evolving
and we you see him he has a couple new
abilities so how is he really coming
into his own with that with his
abilities well we got some stuff coming
for y'all
y'all y'all get ready October 20th
you're gonna be surprised you're gonna
be shocked you're going to be on your
feet you're going to be screaming yeah
don't be crying you're gonna be laughing
so y'all get ready man we got some
powerful stuff coming for y'all I
apologize to employers everywhere
because I hear a lot of people going
I've already booked you know time off
from work you know from around October
20th for like three days
in the house so can you talk about what
are her Ambitions in this game and how
her her storyline has evolved from when
we last saw her yeah I think
as a reporter and as a writer a lot more
um you know she spent a lot of time away
from Peter in simcaria
and she's she am I allowed to say this
um you know she's writing you know
there's a reason why we wanted Yuri
Laura and najiel here because they are a
team they are you know they compliment
each other really well not just what's
going on in the superhero world but
what's happening in their lives and I
think that's why you know I mean even
we're shooting our scenes we're all kind
of working together as a team figuring
out how do we put this game together and
I know I we couldn't be working with
better people like I love these people
they're awesome
[Music]
come on man there's somebody else that
we can't forget about on this planet
the Venom of the minimum
Tony Todd it's truly an honored for have
you on the panel right now ah
yeah and all of a sudden I get a call
from Insomniac to
to test drive Venom and I gotta say it's
been the most exciting voice over
Journey that I've had to date yeah
Ryan uh uh Vera can you just talk about
the casting of this I know is there a
story or something along how this
happened oh yeah
um so I remember we we cast a lot of the
characters pretty quickly like obviously
we had you know miles Peter uh MJ
um and then really early we actually
like right before covet I think we cast
Craven and I knew I was putting off
Venom I was putting it off I was like
I know there's already you know there's
gonna be so many opinions what people
and I know I was scared of death and I
remember uh Patrick our dialogue lead
was asking me like what are you looking
for and I said I don't know and then I
remember
just happened to be on the internet one
day and I was
listening to one of the I think it was
the Candyman uh the new Candyman trailer
and I heard Tony
and I was like
get like a Tony tot that would be the
one and then a couple weeks go by I
don't think anything about it and
Patrick messages me and goes you're not
going to believe this
Tony Todd's interested and I remember he
sent a real quick tape in it was like
sorry Tony it was really bad like audio
quality but he took like three lines and
I was like that's it
please hire him please whatever he wants
give it to him and uh I think I think
you all know based on what you heard
it's it's he's incredible we have a
wonderful we you know there's you know
there's four of us here from insomnic
but we have so many Islamic people
putting so much work through this game
and I again I just want to say if
they're somehow listeners somehow thank
you for all the work that you guys are
putting into it right now it's it's
incredible the work they're doing to
finish this up
my second family because we just put so
much into this and you can imagine when
you're in your family everybody has
opinions right and I think it's probably
the only decision I've ever made being a
creative director in 10 years where I
just said Tony Todd is going to be Venom
and everybody said yes so
um can you just talk a little bit about
Venom's motivations and his personality
in this and and what why is he so
important to The Narrative of this game
well uh yeah I mean
Venom is a symbiote right um and I think
the the thing that um a lot of symbiote
stories have in common and the reason
why I think we we connect with them
really well is that it's it's a simple
human story we we all have a Darkness
inside of us and then you you put the
Symbiote on top of that it really brings
out the the dark parts of what
Spider-Man is about power and
responsibility you heard jury talk about
it
um a couple minutes ago and what happens
in the story is that that sense of
responsibility starts to go away it's
really interesting when you bring the
Symbiote into you know these
relationships uh how it really
challenges them not just externally
because there's cool Powers you know
Ryan was talking about having that that
control in your hand oh my God it's
amazing
um but the the the people you love
around you Tony I'm coming back to you
can you talk about your approach to
bringing the voice of it to life and how
you approached it for me venom was fun
to do and I wanted to make sure that
there was a joyous quality in his in his
destruction I'm glad it was fun for you
because it scared the hell out of us
yeah it'd be funny when we were in the
recording booth because we would record
separately when we were doing gameplay
dialogue and every once in a while Tony
you would come and play in our
headphones before a line and it was like
oh God
I wouldn't expect it and it was
terrifying and Brian I'll come back to
you real quick what was that like when
you heard Tony voice his lines for the
first time officially and what was that
what was your initial reaction
well first relief because I was like
okay we made the right choice for sure
um and I think then just general
excitement and I think
Tony is so talented that you know
sometimes depending on you know we have
so many different characters are so
different so many different actors you
know sometimes we're you know depending
on what the role calls for are we gonna
you know adjust the the way that they do
the line and you just let Tony be Tony
and you get magic uh it was like a gift
come true to be able to
um
uh to submit myself into whole voice
over family and world and meet new
friends and uh conquest and I I'm still
pinching myself because I'm a gamer and
I'm telling you I can't wait for this
Monumental Masterpiece to drop
that's right sizzle
I I be remiss if I didn't ask you can
you do the iconic we are Venom line for
for everybody
bring us all out who do you want no okay
we are
[Applause]
all right well I think we got some some
special surprises coming up for you guys
I think the next thing we want to talk
about is the collector's edition statue
that we have here on this table right
here I I think it really represents what
this game is about you know it you know
I said you know I've said in previous
interviews I've talked about you know
it's called Spider-Man 2 for a reason
because we have two iconic characters
um in this in this great piece of art
but also is it's going to take two
Spider-Man to take on something so
powerful something that they've never
been able that nothing come their way I
mean you know if you look at you know
whether it's Doc Ock in the in the first
game and then Tinker in Miles Morales
like venomizel is literally a whole
different Beast Brian why are you
putting on gloves right now like that's
of these yeah what what is that for well
Dorian before we I think we should play
the video I think we should play the
video let's go and play that video real
quick what oh
miles I need your help what is this
stuff
wait Pete I got an idea
nice one more time on three one two
three
[Applause]
thank you
what
yeah
all right the beautiful Spider-Man 2
PlayStation 5. oh my God
I didn't know about that I didn't know
they didn't show me that before we came
out
hey yeah
that's what they were doing
wow all right well here we go like
Marvel so they they keep everything so
tight little I found out about this five
minutes before we came out here that's
how serious they are so Brian can you
can you speak to this I'm epic amazing
beautifulness right here this has been
one of the biggest secrets throughout
the entire development of the game that
we were gonna have a the console and the
dual shock um so it's I know we're
pretty pumped I mean I think you know we
talk about the Symbiote playing a big
role obviously it plays a big role here
in the design of the console and we
think we think PlayStation for uh going
above and beyond with the design of it I
know I just worked really closely with
everybody on on the design of it and
I I'm pretty pumped man all in all that
being said I want to say thank you again
to this incredible panel thank you guys
so much for all your hard work